[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami beauce world route et
bien joyeux nounours je suis de bonne
humeur pas trop ma petite seul héros
voulons une techno
à l'eau sur la terre
deux bordelais pourront
maintenant aux charlots
oh la la bonsoir du colosse
bonsoir si tu savais que se passe-t-il
et voilà
mon dieu j'en étais sûr pas pr neil
s'est perdu ma pauvre petit pain prône
main assez bien pauvre à deux mois dis
moi tout nicolas je te cool c'est pas
pimprenelle c'est la poupe est un pr
neil qui est perdu au jeu mieux ça et
pape rhône elle où est elle elle pleure
à la salle de bain au sefi
pas prenait allons bon s est en forme et
maintenant ouvre la porte ouvre pas pr
neil c'est moi nous nous
allons ne pleure pas on va la retrouver
ta poupée
[Musique]
ou le tuteur du
oui
il faut demander onguents on a demandé
déjà
ça y est j'ai eu deux quais les demos
divine il faut mettre une annonce donnez
moi du papier et un crayon
voilà de nouveau
parfum là je rédige comment est elle est
là et la moto de petits cheveux bouclés
yassap et
[Musique]
j'ai perdu ma poupée son manteau et rose
ses cheveux sont comment ils se
sont bouclés et elle s'appelle outils
celui qui la rapportera recevra une
récompense
quoi des bambins recevra des bonbons le
veinard a tant qu'il ya des signes pour
qu'on la reconnaisse
la cei et voilà ma petite pape rhône
elle tu peux te coucher tranquille on va
la retrouver
tapie
merci menace
déjà dit et ce que j'écris bien
connu north admet bonne nuit
le petit
pommier pimprenelle dans bien monique il
est fait pour rêve
[Musique]
et
tu es bien pressé de partir on ne nous
fait une course à faire patron une
course urgente
il faut que jacques collet cette annonce
sur un arbre du jardin a lancé vite
nounours bonne eu des enfants
couchez-vous bien sagement est fait de
bouts ronds
oh
[Musique]
vous
oh